[Musique]
je suis né le 9 septembre 1966 la tête à
l'envers dans une chambre de
l'appartement 14 qu'une vague anglaise à
10 heures du soir
mes parents étaient contents et voulien
appelé benjamin hughes mais mes frères
sont intervenus et ont trouvé 6 20
j'avais les cheveux blonds et bouclés
mais ils sont devenus châtain
maintenant ils sont en train de
repousser
j'ai les yeux bleus clairs comme papa je
suis maigre pour mon âge j'ai un teint
blanc et je suis fragile
tu habites le jura
tu aimes le jura c'est une belle région
je pense
tu peux me parler un petit peu de tva
conliège tu vie où tu vis comment avec
qui je crois que je vis un peu tout seul
chien solitaire en plus j'aime bien être
seul chez moi
[Musique]
où
on t'a vu pour la dernière fois
le 29 mars de cette année ça fait un
petit peu plus d'un mois
tout allait bien tout allait bien à ce
moment là qui nous a même appris que tu
suivais des cours de solfège et que tu
jouais de l'ordre depuis deux ans et
demi c'est ce qu'on a appris cette
occasion-là savent pas encore est un peu
d'eux il était un peu secret
ils racontent pas beaucoup enfin on a
appris qu'il souhait de l'homme cette
radiale bravo c'est bon signe d'un
certain côté 1
du point de vue scolaire commence à
sylvain est tombé malade il avait 12 ans
et ceci se passait au mois de septembre
1978 depuis quelques temps il était
fatigué il était pâle il avait des
hémorragies sur la peau et ceci à
motiver consultations médicales et puis
un envoi dans nos services avec un
diagnostic présomptif de saigner aiguë
et ce diagnostic a été confirmé au début
de son hospitalisation et silva a été
traité son traitement et arrêter
maintenant 2 puis
le 15 mai 82 ce qui fait donc bientôt on
te dire pratiquement un an
et depuis la fin de ce traitement n'y a
pas eu d'incidents particuliers
tu m'as dit que tu avais écrit un
journal tu la tenue combien de temps
deux ans je crois
tu l'écris encore
et qu'est ce que tu racontes dans ce
journal
main je raconte tout ce qui se passe
dans la journée les soins
ma vie quoi ce que j'ai vécu à l'hôpital
et puis après chez moi quand j'étais en
repos est ce que c'est parce que tu
étais malade que tu avais envie de vivre
les choses très très vite
tu as été leucémie aiguë c'est une
maladie de la moelle osseuse moi le seul
organe où sont fabriqués normalement les
globules rouges les globules blancs et
ses petites cellules qui servent à la
coagulation du sang et que nous appelons
les plaquettes un moment donné une
cellule va se séparer des autres elle va
évoluer pour son propre compte elle est
devenue le scénic cette cellule va se
multiplier encore une fois pour son
propre compte
séparément des autres
elle ne va pas mature et elle n'aura pas
de propriétés intéressantes en tant que
globules rouges globules blancs ou
plaquettes et progressivement elle va
envahir toute la voile osseuse et de
nombreuses autres organes elle va donc
étouffer toutes les cellules normales le
traitement consiste en quoi
au début c'est un traitement force avec
est avec des perfusions des transfusions
de sang
sans arrêt
après ça se calme un peu l'année et
rendez convient de temps en une semaine
de l'est et des mois avec des
transfusions pendant tes classes mais
aussi aux thérapies a pour but de se
débarrasser et de débarrasser
l'organisme de ces cellules malignes en
réalité un enfant qui est traité pour
une leucémie aiguë va être traité
suivant les cas entre deux ans et demi
et trois ans et très vite au kop ces
deux ans et demi et trois ans le
traitement va être un traitement
d'entretien et ce traitement d'entretien
va permettre une reprise d'une activité
à peu près normale en particulier
scolaire au prix
mme en continu fait à la maison auprès
d'une surveillance très étroite
aussi bien clinique que biologique et
qui va nécessiter des passages à
l'hôpital le souvenir que j'en garde
dix ans il est pas mauvais il est dur il
est dur toi je soulevais quelque chose
de dur mais a posteriori tu reconnais au
fond ce que tu veux dire c'est que
maintenant c'est à ce moment que ça a
été pénible sur le moment ça dure sur
moi c'est très dur voilà ce moment c'est
devenu un bon il faut se dire que il ya
quand même une porte de sortie
heureusement
et qu'elle souviens qu'on s'est revêtue
de la première période de force
on pas un trop mauvais souvenirs je sais
j'étais bien soutenu par mes amis ou
bien gâté premiers parents gt
gt en isolement samedi 21 octobre je
change de sambre et rentre en isolement
dans la chambre d'en face pour la
première fois maman est obligé de se
laver les mains de maître une blouse un
cadeau et un masque pour venir dans ma
chambre
tout ce que je touchais stérile ne
montrent pas aussi
pendant le traitement de force on est
obligé d'isoler l'enfant dans une
chambre stérile parce qu'il n'a plus de
cellules pour se défendre contre les
infections
cet isolement peut durer de une à deux
semaines parfois plus
avant ma maladie j'étais croyant
fois elle est un peu pour moi je
projetais
et puis après on m'a dit je me souviens
au monde j'ai vu que
j'avais beaucoup de monde autour de moi
j'ai compris beaucoup de choses je te
voyais l'hôpital m'a fait comprendre
beaucoup de choses maintenant j'ai une
voie qui s'ouvre une fois il s'ouvre est
plutôt vers les autres j'essaye de leur
faire
voir ce que c'est que jésus
vous comptez 10 à tous et la gravité n'a
pas dit au début
on te disent que
non et comment tu as eu
je crois que j'ai su par petits bouts
agit en retenant des noms d
mais le nom même de la leucémie je ne
sais pas ce que c'était la rue on m'a
peut-être dit ce que c'était que j'avais
la leucémie mais ça m'a rien fait
c'est une maladie inconnue
et tu es interrogé 2000 les médecins les
infirmières tu as cherché dans les
dossiers tu as essayé d'interroger
d'autres malades je crois pas j'ai faim
je me rappelle pas avoir posé de
question et était peut-être mais c'est
sa main je sais ce que j'ai eues me
disant oh ce terme là ne veut ne fait
pas peur et elle me non je n'attache pas
d'importance lieu que je croyais à
douala disons que j'ai été soigné pour
ma maladie mais papa n importe quel me
l'a dit je te barrage aurait une journée
régis barailla voilà donc c'est pas le
terme qui m'a fait peur sylvain canton
commencé la chimiothérapie il ya un
inconvénient c'est très important dans
tout le monde parle c'est la perte des
cheveux ont c'était arrivé aussi comment
tu as vécu sa
patrie mère qu'est ce que ça fait de te
retrouver comme ça jouera qu'un gramme
de de banias
je pense que
ça m'a fait un choc coiffée on avait
prévenu que j'allais perdre mes cheveux
puis j'ai vu d'autres enfants qui n'est
plus de ce monde
pendant ces périodes où tu étais sans
cheveux tu es ricol oui on m'a pas faim
et médecins m'ont poussé à aller nicole
oui qu'est ce que tu as dit à tes
copains ce que tu portes un bonnet qui
sonne je leur ai dit elle
je n'ai pas dit grand chose il en rit et
on peut poser la question pourquoi tu
portes un bonnet tout le temps même en
place je crois que les professeurs leur
avait dit
finalement quand tu as perdu tu joues
dans un premier temps j'ai perdu mes
cheveux a longtemps donné par ton et
après un petit peu j'ai pleuré parce que
je lisais à j'ai perdu mes beaux cheveux
mais après je me suis donné mais il ya
une fille dans ma classe les très
méchants parce que après la récréation
des fois elles bougent pas malade et les
cheveux elle touche les cheveux devant
noah alors des fois ça nous donne envie
de pleurer a coiffé sa j'étais bête
qu'est ce que ma maman à juin a dit m
une perruque dans ce nouveau classement
quel toit moi j'ai dû mais non ça me
gêne et maintenant je regrette de pas
voir mon bébé parce que sinon personne
ne le sera et cette chute des cheveux
vous bien savoir qu'elle n'est que
temporaire qu'elle va guérir les cheveux
voire pousser et que ce qui est
considéré à juste titre comme très
désagréable par les enfants et parents
famille ne sera qu'un moment dans la
maladie et bientôt un mauvais souvenir
quels rapports tu avais avec les
médecins ou les infirmières je crois que
j'avais de très bons rapports est très
gentil avec eux et que les infirmières
les auxiliaires puéricultrices surtout
qui s'occupait de moi tous les jours
qu'ils étaient aux petits soins aux
petits soins avec moi de leur chouchou
oui
il était plein d'humour il aimait bien
jouer
je passais beaucoup de temps à jouer
avec des jeux électroniques
il nous posait beaucoup de questions
et je crois que progressivement il s'est
très vite posé la question à savoir une
qu'elles sont malades ils avaient en
fait et je porte très vite il a eu un
doute sur sa maladie
mais en fait il n'a jamais voulu aborder
directement un problème avignon est ce
qui t'es arrivé de penser que
tu aurais pu ne pas guérir
et peut-être
mais je n'avais pas peur
qui n'a jamais eu peur
alors la mort c'était quoi pour toi
t
peut-être le début d'une autre vie
voilà pour tout vous dire j'aime la vie
mais je n'aime pas la pollution les
riches et la guerre j'aime la nature la
forêt les promenades les animaux et tous
mes amis et amies
pour revenir la maladie
à savoir comment tes parents mon vécu ça
qui nous l'a pas dit
ben
moi j'ai vu
très calme quand je te malade j'ai vu
qu'il me soutenait moralement je pense
que mais aussi de bien me le faire vivre
à moi mais je ne sais pas trop comment
véhicule
on n'a pas coupé la considérait
d'ailleurs lui-même il santé s'était
bien qu'on considère pas comme un malade
ne fait pas le considérer comme un être
comme une personne normale c'est que le
dr nous avait dit d'ailleurs il fallait
qu'il continue ses études qui vivent
normalement
sans qu'on sent comme sache nouveau
presque pas l'ignorer sa maladie et que
lui adresse la ligne
qu'est ce qui l'a aidée à tenir le coup
mes parents cela mes parents m'ont
vraiment pensé parce que c'était pas
facile tous les jours disons que moi je
suis moi j'aurais vous reprochez pas
avoir de sentiment que j'avais passé par
là donc ils ne savaient pas je ne savais
pas comment c'était dur pour moi
personne ne pouvait savoir comment
c'était dur
donc les personnes qui le poussait pour
moi c'est des personnes le sentiment qui
me poussait sans le savoir oui well well
envoyé 10 dans le bourg et puis
maintenant dommage réaliste heureusement
que actuellement dans le cadre des
leucémies aiguës lymphoblastiques d'un
enfant qui sont les tumeurs les plus
fréquentes de l'enfant on obtient ce que
nous appelons une rémission complète qui
va durer dans plus d'un cas sur deux
dont plus de la moitié des cas qui va
durer plus de cinq ans et au delà de 5
ans et à partir de cette date des cinq
ans le la probabilité de rechute devient
extrêmement faible et actuellement les
rémission complète que l'on obtient sont
en nombre important et ceci justifie
l'espoir que l'on peut mettre dans le
traitement de ces maladies sylvain quels
conseils tu peux donner à ceux qui ont
la même maladie que toi
un leur dire de prendre courage de
rester courageux
pas flanché
penser que les assortirons
[Musique]